Jake:发牌在线发牌哦小彩旗
Jake: Dealing cards online, little flag
Jake:这个厨房的
Jake: This kitchen's
Jake:厨房柜子下面的应该
Jake: Probably under the kitchen cabinet
Tasha: 怎么个事呢
Tasha: What's the deal?
Tasha: 居然是这样子贴的好吧
Tasha: It's actually stuck like this, okay
Jake:我给你串
Jake: I'll string it for you
Tasha: 现在就穿吗
Tasha: Now?
Jake:那我干点啥
Jake: Then what should I do?
Tasha: 那你穿吧
Tasha: Then you do it
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay
Jake:我回头做PPT呢
Jake: I'll make the PPT later
Jake:我应该把他的那个卡瑞纳呢
Jake: I should put his Karina in it
Jake:给他写上去
Jake: Write it down for him
Jake:这是线啊这啥啊
Jake: Is this a wire or what?
其他人：粘粘呢直接贴起来
Others: Stick it directly
Tasha: 我觉得这个不粘吧
Tasha: I think it won't stick
Jake:这就是线吗应该吧
Jake: This is a wire, right?
Tasha: 应该吧
Tasha: I guess
Jake:噢对就是破防
Jake: Oh right, it's breaking defense
Jake:你就被他破防了
Jake: You've been broken by him
Jake:他去买了个药
Jake: He went to buy medicine
Jake:然后你拿了药他说他有
Jake: Then you took the medicine, he said he had it
Jake:就是这样
Jake: That's it
其他人：就这样补什么药啊
Others: Why do you need medicine for this?
Tasha: 感冒药呀
Tasha: Cold medicine!
Shure: 他怎么还感冒了呢
Shure: How did he catch a cold?
Jake:他感冒了呀
Jake: He's got a cold.
Tasha: 他
Tasha: He...
Shure: 是啊怎么这么脆弱呢
Shure: Yeah, how is he so fragile?
Tasha: 就是呗
Tasha: Exactly.
Jake:有顺序吗
Jake: Is there an order?
Shure: 别传染给我吧
Shure: Don't infect me.
Jake:没有顺序
Jake: No order.
Tasha: 不知道呀没有吧
Tasha: No idea, maybe not.
Shure: 你快回学校吧你
Shure: You should head back to school.
Jake:哎哈喽
Jake: Hey, hello.
Jake:哈喽啊
Jake: Hello there.
其他人：你们好
Others: Hi, everyone.
Shure: 麦克风拿来了吧
Shure: Did you bring the microphone?
Jake:有电有电
Jake: There's power, there's power.
Jake:这边有电
Jake: There's power here.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Jake:哦好嘞
Jake: Oh, got it.
Shure: 这放二楼吧
Shure: Let's put it on the second floor.
Shure: 到时咱都在二楼
Shure: We'll all be on the second floor.
Tasha: 怎么样哪个好看
Tasha: What do you think, which one looks better?
Shure: 这不是我们宿舍那小推车吗哈哈哈
Shure: Isn't this the little cart from our dorm? Hahaha.
Alice:来
Alice: Come.
Jake:都都挺好看真的
Jake: They all look great, really.
Jake:第一个好看
Jake: The first one looks good.
Tasha: 你知道这些要怎么操作吗
Jake:我不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Shure: 哈厨邦酱油美味鲜是吧
Shure: Is it Ha Kitchen's delicious soy sauce?
Tasha: 那你好有品味啊
Jake:我这个应该放后头对吧
Jake: Should I put this at the back, right?
Jake:哎呦卧槽
Jake: Oh, damn.
Tasha: 五十六个民族五十六朵花
Tasha: Fifty-six ethnic groups, fifty-six flowers.
Tasha: 五十六个中华民族是一家
Tasha: Fifty-six ethnic groups in China, we are one family.
Jake:一家
Jake: One family.
Tasha: 噔噔噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun dun dun.
Tasha: 哒哒哒哒
Tasha: Da da da da.
Jake:来串串
Jake: Let's barbecue.
Jake:咱有咱有几个串
Jake: How many skewers do we have?
Jake:咱就一个串
Jake: We have just one skewer.
Tasha: 两个串
Tasha: Two skewers.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Jake:那串一下
Jake: So, let's connect it
其他人：今天下午会多来多少人
Others: How many more people will come this afternoon?
Jake:不知道
Jake: No idea
其他人：怎么串
Others: How do we connect it?
Jake:还有一个
Jake: There's one more
Jake:就as simple as it is OK
Jake: Just as simple as it is, OK
其他人： OK
Others: OK
Tasha: 清华清华生还需要你教吗
Tasha: Do Tsinghua students still need your teaching?
Tasha: 人家自学看看就懂了是吧
Tasha: They can just teach themselves, right?
其他人：Zero shot learning
Others: Zero-shot learning
Jake:对Zero shot连Tiss都不要给
Jake: Yeah, zero-shot, don't even need Tiss
Alice:没有方向的黎明
Alice: A dawn without direction
Shure: 买打火机你会省心
Shure: If you buy a lighter, you'll save yourself some trouble
Shure: 买烟他不会的吧
Shure: But he won't buy cigarettes, right?
其他人：只需要给我一个东西我就可以对你
Others: Just give me one thing and I can do it for you
Jake:就知道你要干什么
Jake: Then you'll know what you need to do
其他人：先做这个认知推理
Others: First, do the cognitive reasoning
Tasha: 好今天把面粉给他
Tasha: Okay, give him the flour today
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Jake:给你推理推理
Jake: Let you reason this out
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
其他人：面粉这个可以吗
Tasha: 你觉得可以吗
Tasha: Do you think it's okay?
Jake:呵我你问他可不可以
Jake: Haha, ask him if it's okay
其他人：面粉给我就哭
Others: If you give me the flour, I'll cry
其他人： 打auto memory了哈哈
Others: Auto memory triggered, haha
Tasha: 不用这样子
Tasha: No need to do it this way
Jake:不行要你有
Jake: No, you need to have it
Tasha: 你有你有点强迫症的
Tasha: You have a bit of OCD
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no
Tasha: 没有没有弄成这样子干嘛
Tasha: If not, why do it this way?
Jake:就是要弄成这样子
Jake: It has to be done this way
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Tasha: 我看看这个人会不会
Tasha: Let me see if this person can do it
Jake:这人也会的
Jake: This person can do it too
Tasha: 我不信
Tasha: I don't believe it
其他人：我不信应该不就应该是这样吗
Others: I don't believe it, should be like this, right?
Jake:是吧
Jake: Right?
Tasha: 就是要理这么顺吗
Tasha: Does it have to be this neat?
Jake:对对吧对啊要不然呢
Jake: Yes, yes, right, otherwise what?
Jake:还能拧成麻花嘛对吧
Jake: Or else it will twist into a mess, right?
Tasha: 搞快点还要做甜品呢
Tasha: Hurry up, we still have to make desserts.
Jake:哦哦哦好好好
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, okay, okay, okay.
Tasha: 来不及了
Tasha: We’re running out of time.
Tasha: 几点了
Tasha: What time is it?
Tasha: 12点了我靠
Tasha: It's already 12, oh my god.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 几点钟几点钟
Tasha: What time is it exactly?
Jake:两点半
Jake: It's 2:30.
Tasha: 那个两点半
Tasha: It's 2:30.
Tasha: 房间还没装饰呢
Tasha: The room hasn't been decorated yet.
Jake:呃对
Jake: Uh, right.
Jake:房间装好
Jake: Finish decorating the room.
Tasha: 别穿了
Tasha: Stop dressing.
Jake:走走
Jake: Let's go, let's go.
Jake:呵呵那只剩抖叉叉来穿了
Jake: Haha, only Jack is left to dress.
Jake:哈哈加油
Jake: Haha, keep it up.
Tasha: 还要做甜品吗
Tasha: Do we still need to make desserts?
Jake:对对对来穿一穿吧
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, let's dress it up.
Jake:辛苦你了
Jake: Thanks for your hard work.
其他人：中午吃啥呀
Others: What’s for lunch?
Jake:呃还没点呢
Jake: Uh, we haven't ordered yet.
其他人：还没点呀
Others: You haven't ordered yet?
其他人：那我建议你
Others: Then I suggest...
其他人：我饿
Others: I'm hungry.
Jake:我觉得你这个好
Jake: I think your suggestion is good.
Jake:建议来
Jake: Suggest something.
Tasha: 今天早上粥吃完了吗先垫垫
Tasha: Did you finish the porridge from this morning? Have some first.
Jake:对我们还有点油条
Jake: Yes, we still have some youtiao.
Jake:万一呢我们还有汉堡
Jake: Just in case, we also have burgers.
Jake:我们还有昨天晚上吃的汉堡
Jake: We still have the burgers from last night.
Jake:有人没吃
Jake: Someone didn't eat.
Jake:两个30多块钱两个
Jake: Two for over 30 bucks each.
Jake:最贵的没吃
Jake: The most expensive ones weren't eaten.
其他人：怎么有人没吃
Others: How come someone didn't eat?
Jake:我怎么知道有人没吃
Jake: How would I know someone didn't eat?
Jake:你先吃吃你吃不了的你就点
Jake: You eat first, if you can't finish, then order.
Tasha: 哎你干嘛去
Tasha: Hey, where are you going?
Jake:我不是要给你收拾吗
Jake: Wasn't I going to clean up for you?
Tasha: 你拿东西了吗
Tasha: Did you take the stuff?
其他人：怎么你怎么这这让我点了呢
Others: Why did you let me order this?
Jake:那要不你先看看吃
Jake: How about you check the food first?
其他人：吃什么我先看吃什么啊
Others: What should I check first?
Jake:对对对你先
Jake: Yeah, yeah, you first.
Jake:你先点嘛
Jake: You order first.
Jake:我拿上去
Jake: I'll take it up.
Jake:是吗
Jake: Really?
Jake:我还要拿什么上去
Jake: What else do I need to take up?
Jake:这什么东西
Jake: What's this?
Tasha: 这个这个
Tasha: This, this one.
Jake:这个这个我靠
Jake: This, this, damn.
Jake:我这个没手拿
Jake: I don't have enough hands to carry this.
Jake:我拿上去
Jake: I'll take it up.
Jake:这个有点危险
Jake: This is a bit dangerous.
Jake:牛啊
Jake: Awesome.
Tasha: 不然您还想去哪个频道
Tasha: Where else do you want to go?
Shure: 对这才是那味
Shure: Yeah, this is the right vibe.
Shure: 我们在收拾这个桌子
Shure: We're cleaning this table.
Shure: 你又往这点放
Shure: And you're putting stuff here again.
Jake:我往这里面放
Jake: I'm putting it here.
Jake:往床上往地上放
Jake: On the bed, on the floor.
Shure: 菊次郎没有熬过的夏天
Shure: A summer that Juzo didn't endure.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 这谁的
Shure: Whose is this?
Shure: 这是什么
Shure: What is this?
Shure: 卧槽
Shure: Damn.
其他人：给你找个凳子
Others: Get you a chair.
Shure: 这应该不能吃了吧
Shure: This shouldn't be edible, right?
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my.
Shure: 这真的是土耳其的吗
Shure: Is this really from Turkey?
Jake:创作歌手
Jake: Singer-songwriter.
Shure: 你的土耳其
Shure: Your Turkey.
Shure: 我的土耳其
Shure: My Turkey.
Shure: 好像不一样是吧
Shure: Seems different, right?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 卧槽
Shure: Damn.
Shure: 你这土耳其真的跟我们的很很不一样
Shure: Your Turkey is really quite different from ours.
Jake:你这拖拉机在打仗啊
Jake: Is your tractor at war?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Jazz版土耳其是吧
Shure: 啊我操
Shure: 到时候视频就是
Shure: 哎我逼
Jake:我的线在哪啊
Tasha: 在楼上好
Jake:是的在准备
Jake:在楼上
Jake:走走走走走走
Tasha: 干嘛
Jake:拿线
Jake:然后插上
Tasha: 然后呢然后呢
Jake:然后给你打扫
Jake:我的线在哪啊
Tasha: 哈哈
Jake:给他印俩眼睛呗
Jake: Give him a couple of eyes.
Jake:你的线呢
Jake: Where's your cord?
Tasha: 我的线在楼下
Tasha: My cord's downstairs.
Tasha: 哈哈哈不用充了刚看了
Tasha: Haha, no need to charge it, just checked.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:你的线在哪个楼下
Jake: Which downstairs?
Tasha: 在椅子上
Tasha: On the chair.
Tasha: 我的你会摇扇子吗哈哈
Shure: 来一个
Shure: Give it a try.
Shure: 能咬吗能咬能咬
Shure: Can you bite it? Yes, you can.
Tasha: 能咬能咬
Tasha: Yes, you can.
Tasha: 展开再咬然后合上的
Tasha: Open it, bite it, then close it.
Shure: 好我知道了想你了
Shure: Got it, I miss you.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:美美
Jake: Beautiful.
Tasha: 太美了
Tasha: So beautiful.
Shure: 舍弃吗
Shure: Give up?
Jake:美美射
Jake: Beautiful shot.
Shure: 够舍吗
Shure: Give up enough?
Jake:多多少刚出院
Jake: How much, just discharged?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Jake:出院多久了
Jake: How long have you been discharged?
Jake:麦克风
Jake: Microphone.
Jake:我要干什么
Jake: What should I do?
Tasha: 把被子叠上
Tasha: Fold the blanket.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 行谢谢你
Tasha: Alright, thank you.
Shure: 7天第一次叠叠被子是吧
Shure: First time folding a blanket in 7 days, huh?
Tasha: 谁起你天天叠吗
Tasha: Who folds it every day?
Shure: 我不叠啊
Tasha: 那不就行了
Tasha: Then that's fine.
Jake:那那也是七天叠一次
Tasha: 把被子放这合上
Tasha: Put the blanket here and fold it.
Jake:好合上
Jake: Okay, fold it.
Tasha: 因为
Tasha: Because...
Tasha: 我居然发现他又给我发了一床被子
Tasha: I found out he sent me another blanket.
Jake:怕你冻着
Jake: Afraid you'd get cold.
Tasha: 等等enjoy your my day
Tasha: Anyway, enjoy your day.
Tasha: 往那边再放一点
Tasha: Move it a bit over there.
Tasha: 为什么不钉在墙上呢
Tasha: Why not nail it to the wall?
Jake:那个小玩意
Jake: That little thing...
Tasha: 因为他不给钉
Tasha: Because he won't nail it.
Jake:那个小玩意
Jake: That little thing...
Tasha: 哪个
Tasha: Which one?
Tasha: 那个是你要吗
Tasha: Is that the one you want?
Jake:我不要我要把它放正
Jake: No, I want to straighten it.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 这样吗
Tasha: Like this?
Jake:他得出来吧
Jake: It should come out, right?
Jake:是不
Jake: Isn't it?
Tasha: 是的呢
Tasha: Yes, it is.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 怎么搞怎么办
Tasha: What to do, what to do...
Jake:哎呦
Jake: Oh man.
Jake:你做衣服吧要不
Jake: How about you make some clothes?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 怎么搞你会铺床单吗
Tasha: What to do, can you put on the bed sheet?
Jake:这个不够长吧
Jake: This isn't long enough, right?
Tasha: 好像没有到两张床的长度吧
Tasha: Seems like it's not long enough for two beds.
Tasha: 你会不会太过分了
Tasha: Aren't you being too much?
其他人：操你还会这个
Others: Damn, you can do this too?
Tasha: 不得不嫁了是吧已经
Tasha: You have no choice but to get married, right?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
其他人：快了是拦不下了
Others: Yeah, it's unstoppable now.
Jake:完了一天求婚80遍我靠
Jake: Proposing 80 times a day, oh my god.
Tasha: 就这样吧
Tasha: Let's just do it this way.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
其他人：你学的这种琴还是钢琴
Others: Did you learn this kind of instrument or piano?
其他人：钢琴
Others: Piano.
Jake:这个给他套起来吗
Jake: Should we wrap this up for him?
Tasha: 你会什么乐器吗
Tasha: Do you play any instruments?
Jake:不会
Jake: No.
Tasha: 好我也不
Tasha: Okay, me neither.
Tasha: 会那就好
Tasha: That's good then.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 已经变了
Tasha: It's already changed.
Tasha: 已经变样了房间
Tasha: The room looks different now.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Tasha: 完了明天还要拆掉
Tasha: We'll have to take it down tomorrow.
Jake:没关系
Jake: It's okay.
Jake:明天慢慢拆
Jake: We'll take it down slowly tomorrow.
其他人：那建议今天你表演
Others: So we suggest you perform today.
其他人：你快来表演一个
Others: Come on, perform something.
其他人：匈牙利狂想曲
Others: Hungarian Rhapsody.
Jake:建议你们看看有没有火药杆
Jake: I suggest you check if there's any gunpowder.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
其他人：我已经串完了
Others: I've already skewered it.
其他人：建议你现在点外卖啊
Others: Suggest you order takeout now.
Tasha: 两两个串吗
Tasha: Two skewers?
Tasha: 两个串都串完了
Tasha: Both skewers are done.
其他人：哦还有他那个场
Others: Oh, there's his venue too.
其他人：没事马上我就去穿
Others: No worries, I'll skewer it soon.
Jake:哇那你点
Jake: Wow, then you order.
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow.
Jake:你问他们想试什么
Jake: Ask them what they want to try.
其他人：我的评价是元记云饺
Others: My recommendation is Yuanji Yun Dumplings.
Jake:好行那你开吧
Jake: Okay, then you open it.
其他人：不如吃拌饭
Others: How about bibimbap?
Tasha: 我也觉得米村拌饭好吃
Tasha: I also think Micun bibimbap is delicious.
Tasha: 搜就知道了
Tasha: Just search and you'll know.
其他人：预制菜预制菜
Others: Pre-made dishes, pre-made dishes.
Jake:哈哈哈那我不要老北京
Jake: Hahaha, then I don't want the old Beijing style.
其他人：那我不要
Others: Then I don't want it.
Shure: 老老北京就好这口元记云饺
Shure: 预制菜哈哈
Shure: Pre-made dishes, haha.
Jake:别的可是也是预制菜
Jake: But the other ones are also pre-made dishes.
Jake:只是没告诉你自己
Jake: They just didn't tell you.
Tasha: 云记云脚也是预制菜
Tasha: Yunji and Yunfoot are also pre-made dishes.
其他人：真的吗真的
Others: Really? Really.
Tasha: 真的每天小车拉过来的
Tasha: Really, they get delivered by a small truck every day.
Jake:那就就吃那个什么叫什么
Jake: Then let's just eat that... what's it called...
Jake:白饭哈哈
Jake: Plain rice, haha.
Tasha: 米村拌饭
Tasha: Micun Bibimbap.
Jake:米村拌饭
Jake: Micun Bibimbap.
Jake:行
Jake: Okay.
Jake:来
Jake: Let's go.
Tasha: 您看你一看在家就没套过被子是吧
Tasha: It seems like you've never made your bed at home, right?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:套过套过套过
Jake: I have, I have, I have.
Tasha: 套过套过
Tasha: You have?
Tasha: 你跟我说你不知道这样
Tasha: But you told me you didn't know how to.
Jake:我知道我知道
Jake: I know, I know.
Tasha: 你不知道
Tasha: You don't know.
Jake:我我可能知道
Jake: I might know.
Jake:你你知道
Jake: You, you know.
Jake:我我我这次拨你
Jake: This time, I'll beat you.
Tasha: 就是那个10块钱配送费的
Tasha: It's that one with the 10 yuan delivery fee.
Tasha: 就他
Tasha: That one.
Jake:好行
Jake: Okay, fine.
Tasha: 就他一家
Tasha: That one place.
Lucia: 好那我单独点
Lucia: Okay, then I'll order separately.
其他人:  我觉得元记云饺快可以先吃上
其他人：我还会我会最简单的
Others: I can, I can do the simplest one.
Jake:好听
Jake: Sounds good.
Jake:牛逼虽然是这是啥呀
Jake: Awesome, but what is this?
Jake:这哈哈哈
Jake: This, haha.
Jake:这啥呀哦嘿
Jake: What is this? Oh hey.
Jake:行行行自创了是吧
Jake: Okay, okay, you made it up yourself, right?
Jake:自创歌曲
Jake: Your own song.
Tasha: 想喝水了
Tasha: I'm thirsty.
Jake:想喝水了
Jake: I'm thirsty.
Jake:嗯好
Jake: Yeah, okay.
Jake:给您倒水
Jake: Let me pour you some water.
Jake:您有杯子吗
Jake: Do you have a cup?
Tasha: 没有没杯子
Tasha: No, I don't have a cup.
Lucia: 哦这是巴赫的一个小步舞曲是吧
Lucia: Oh, this is a minuet by Bach, right?
Tasha: 我在充电是吗
Tasha: Am I charging?
Lucia: 好像是练完拜
Lucia: Seems like after practicing Bye.
Lucia: 练完拜厄的第一首曲子就弹这个
Lucia: After practicing Bye's first piece, you play this one.
Jake:挺好鼓手
Jake: Pretty good drummer.
Jake:咱就干鼓手的事情哈哈哈
Jake: Let's just do drummer's work, haha.
Shure: 怎么
Shure: What?
Shure: 鼓手怎么了
Shure: What's up with the drummer?
其他人：这谁的这谁的手机
Others: Whose phone is this?
Shure: 鼓手我还可以弹这个呢
Shure: I, as a drummer, can also play this.
Jake:我的
Jake: It's mine.
Jake:点完了
Jake: I've ordered.
Jake:大家都点完了
Jake: Everyone has ordered.
其他人：对 10个人
Others: Yes, 10 people.
Jake:好那就直接下单了
Jake: Alright, let's place the order then.
其他人：10个人20块
Others: 10 people, 20 bucks.
其他人：呃200块钱
Others: Uh, 200 bucks.
Jake:这么便宜
Jake: So cheap.
其他人：让我看一眼
Others: Let me take a look.
其他人：我看一眼
Jake:你再看一眼
Jake: Take another look.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Haha.
其他人：1234567 呃
Others: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, uh...
Lucia: 对但是
Lucia: Yes, but...
Lucia: 我感觉这个就是
Lucia: I feel like this is...
Lucia: 因为它本身是应该撕下
Lucia: Because it should be torn off.
Lucia: 直接贴墙上的
Lucia: And directly pasted on the wall.
Lucia: 但我又害怕直接贴墙上会撕不下来
Lucia: But I'm afraid if I paste it directly on the wall, it won't come off.
其他人：OK
Others: OK.
其他人：这回是OK
Others: This time, it's OK.
Lucia: 所以大的那几个
Lucia: So, for the bigger ones...
Lucia: 我都是给它后面粘了胶带贴的
Lucia: I put tape on the back to stick them.
Lucia: 但是它不是有颜色吗
Lucia: But it's colored, right?
Jake:怎么多了100块钱
Jake: Why is there an extra 100 bucks?
Lucia: 就是本来应该透明就是边上都透明的
Lucia: It should be transparent, like the edges should be transparent.
Jake:哈哈哈因为之前是
Jake: Haha, because before it was...
Lucia: 这样他就变白了
Lucia: Now it turned white.
Tasha: 多了5个菜
Tasha: We got five more dishes.
Lucia: 然后就没那么好看了救命
Lucia: And now it doesn't look as good, help!
其他人：就是现在是相当于一人一个菜
Others: So now it's like one dish per person.
Lucia: 我想牺牲一点美观性
Lucia: I want to sacrifice a bit of aesthetics.
其他人：然后98个菜
Others: Then 98 dishes.
其他人：9个人8 哎
Others: Nine people, eight... hey.
其他人：9个 10个人8个菜
Others: Nine, ten people, eight dishes.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:来给您倒水
Jake: Let me pour you some water.
Alice:的名字
Alice: The name.
Lucia: 对哈哈
Lucia: Yeah, haha.
Lucia: 虽然我房间有点乱
Lucia: Although my room is a bit messy.
Lucia: 但是貌似好像大家都在录的样子
Lucia: But it seems like everyone is recording.
Lucia: 所以应该房间里也是可以录的
Lucia: So it should be okay to record in the room too.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 恰one yeah特特
Shure: Check one, yeah, test test.
Shure: 稍等啊
Shure: Hold on.
Jake:这特效太高了
Jake: These effects are too high.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Shure: 喂喂喂耶
Shure: Hey hey hey, yeah.
Shure: yeah yeah yeah
Shure: Yeah yeah yeah.
Shure: yeah
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: ladies and gentlemen
Shure: Ladies and gentlemen.
Shure: now let's welcome to ego life world
Shure: Now let's welcome you to the ego life world.
Jake:牛逼
Jake: Awesome!
其他人：味太臭了味太臭了
Others: The smell is too bad, the smell is too bad.
Jake:牛逼
Jake: Awesome!
Shure: today we will have a great and brain party
Shure: Today we will have a great and brainy party.
Shure: it's called ego party
Shure: It's called the ego party.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Jake:要要
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake:我操
Jake: Oh shit.
Jake:要不抓几个人下去打工吧
Jake: How about we grab a few people to go work?
Jake:你们抓你们
Jake: You guys grab them.
Jake:抓几个人
Jake: Grab a few people.
Jake:你们
Jake: You guys.
Jake:你下去打工吧
Jake: You go work.
Jake:要不下去收拾收拾
Jake: Or go clean up downstairs.
其他人：底下那个卡换了没
Others: Did they change the card downstairs?
Jake:都换了
Jake: Everything's been replaced.
Jake:但是你得收拾收拾
Jake: But you need to tidy up.
Jake:这边这边这边
Jake: Over here, over here.
Tasha: 说啥
Tasha: What did you say?
Tasha: 这个吗我已经收过一遍了哦
Tasha: This one? I've already cleaned it once.
Jake:那就再说一遍
Jake: Then do it again.
Jake:垃圾啊什么的
Jake: Trash and stuff.
Jake:呃就放上面这个
Jake: Uh, just put it on top.
Jake:就是摆好陨树桌子
Jake: Just set up the tree table nicely.
Jake:就是要给他摆好动一下
Jake: Just need to arrange it properly, move it a bit.
Jake:怎么了
Jake: What's wrong?
Alice:没事
Alice: Nothing.
Shure: （歌词）原谅我一生不羁放纵爱自由
Shure: (lyrics) Forgive me for a lifetime of rebelliousness and love for freedom.
Shure: （歌词）也会怕有一天会跌倒oh no
Shure: (lyrics) I'm also afraid of falling one day, oh no.
Shure: （歌词）谁人都可以
Shure: (lyrics) Anyone can do it.
Alice:太优雅了
Alice: So elegant.
其他人：我还可以弹autoking你知道吗
Alice:啊薇薇你咋样了
Alice: Ah, Tasha, how are you?
Shure: 好OK
Shure: Alright, OK.
Shure: 呀
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 我说句话
Shure: Let me say something.
Shure: 他现在就会有点耶
Shure: He'll feel a bit "yay" now.
Shure: 哎不对
Shure: Wait, that's not right.
Shure: 不够等一下
Shure: Not enough, hold on.
Shure: cowarding scent
Shure: Cowarding scent.
Shure: （歌词）yeah response in the tab going in
Shure: (lyrics) Yeah, response in the tab going in.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Shure: （歌词）novembering i feel so lonely
Shure: (lyrics) Novembering, I feel so lonely.
Shure: （歌词） so decided gonna be my soul
Shure: (lyrics) So decided, gonna be my soul.
其他人：修硕你来唱我来弹
Others: Shure, you sing, I'll play.
Shure: 谈什么
Shure: Play what?
Shure: 唱什么
Shure: Sing what?
Shure: yeah
Shure: Yeah.
Jake:呃呃呃呵呵
Jake: Uh uh uh, haha.
Jake:好听呵呵呵
Jake: Sounds good, haha.
Shure: 你在唱什么呀
Shure: What are you singing?
其他人：学习联系非党员同学线下交流
Others: Study and connect with non-party classmates offline.
其他人：你是党员是吗
Others: Are you a party member?
其他人： 对啊就不能做哼
Others: Yeah, so I can't do it, huh.
Jake:这些多理解啊
Jake: Understand it more.
Jake:我不是
Jake: I'm not.
其他人：哈哈哈真的
Other People: Haha, really.
其他人：我们我们
Other People: We, we...
其他人：我们系的那个
Other People: Our department...
其他人：然后优先选择发展型
Other People: Then we prioritize the developers.
其他人：对啊手敲了
Other People: Yeah, hand...
其他人：在word上手敲了
其他人：连注意力都没有纯手指
Other People: No attention, just purely by hand.
其他人：万一说错了呢
其他人：说错了说错了
Other People: Say it wrong then.
其他人：我才有缺点呀
Other People: I have flaws too.
其他人：我是因为我理论学习不到位
Other People: Because my theoretical study is insufficient.
Shure: 他要啥都说对
Shure: If he says everything right.
其他人：我都比他中国话好
其他人：我说错才显得我几个学习依然有缺陷
Other People: Saying it wrong shows that my studies still have flaws.
其他人：思想觉悟还不够高
其他人：还有提升的空间
Other People: There's room for improvement.
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh...
Jake:有是有但是可能
Jake: There is, but maybe...
Jake:买一点可
Jake: Buy a little.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
其他人：这是什么
Other People: What's this?
Tasha: 蒸蛋吧
Tasha: Steamed egg, maybe.
Jake:买的是吧
Jake: Did you buy it?
Tasha: 不知道谁的
Tasha: Not sure whose it is.
Jake:这早早餐早餐早餐早餐
Jake: This is breakfast, breakfast, breakfast, breakfast.
Jake:干啥呢
Jake: What are you doing?
Tasha: 小彩彩穿完了吗
Tasha: Is Katrina done dressing?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
其他人：多问一句就要多讲
Others: If you ask more, you have to explain more.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:那你要不到外面学去
Jake: How about you go outside and learn?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Jake:穿完了吗
Jake: Are you done dressing?
Jake:好好
Jake: Okay, okay.
Tasha: 上楼贴贴上好对走
Tasha: Go upstairs and put it up properly, then go.
Jake:嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟
Jake: Doo doo doo doo doo.
Tasha: 变了没
Tasha: Has it changed?
Jake:变了
Jake: It has changed.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Oh my.
Jake:这是哪啊
Jake: Where is this?
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 贴在这吧
Tasha: Let's stick it here.
Jake:看怎么捋一下
Jake: Let's see how to smooth it out.
Tasha:  就用这卷胶代替吧
Tasha: Let's just use this roll of tape instead.
Jake:好我先捋一下
Jake: Okay, I'll smooth it out first.
Jake:我靠我们就一串就行了是吧
Jake: Oh my, we only need one string, right?
Tasha: 呃这还可以再贴出来
Tasha: Uh, we can stick more if you want.
Tasha: 如果你想要一
Tasha: If you want one...
Jake:哎呦
Jake: Oh no.
Jake:这么长
Jake: So long.
Tasha: 哎哎
Tasha: Hey hey.
Jake:哎哎呀呀
Jake: Hey hey yeah yeah.
Jake:捋一下
Jake: Smooth it out.
其他人：对头了
Others: It's right.
Jake:对头了对头了对头了
Jake: It's right, it's right, it's right.
Jake:哎好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:这把对头了
Jake: This time it's right.
Tasha: 我拽着这头从这头开始贴
Tasha: I'll hold this end and start sticking from here.
Jake:拽着这一头你你从这头开始贴
Jake: Hold this end, and you start sticking from here.
Jake:好我贴哪去好
Jake: Okay, where should I stick it?
Tasha: 贴这
Tasha: Stick it here.
Tasha: 嗯不是用这只这只
Tasha: No, not with this one, with this one.
Tasha: 你就把他从这开始贴
Tasha: Start sticking from here.
Jake:嗯好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: yes yes OK OK
Tasha: Yes yes, okay okay.
Tasha: 上
Tasha: Go up.
Jake:我去哪里
Jake: Where should I go?
Tasha: 这里
Tasha: Here.
Jake:这里
Jake: Here?
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: Yes.
Jake:这可以贴墙哈
Jake: I can stick this on the wall, right?
Tasha: 这个可以撕下来
Tasha: This can be peeled off.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Jake:这样嗯嗯
Jake: Like this, mm-hmm.
Tasha: 你贴个头也行
Tasha: You can stick the top part too.
Jake:好那我就贴个头
Jake: Okay, I’ll stick the top part.
Jake:我就贴
Jake: I'll stick it.
Tasha: 那你贴一齐吧
Tasha: Stick it all together.
Jake:我把我把第一个给贴起来
Jake: I'll stick the first part.
Tasha: 嗯嗯贴一齐
Tasha: Mm-hmm, stick it all together.
Jake:然后把它撕掉
Jake: Then peel it off.
Jake:我来我来我来了
Jake: I got it, I got it, I'm coming.
Tasha:    要用剪刀把那个剪掉
Tasha: You need to cut that off with scissors.
Jake:把谁剪掉
Jake: Cut what off?
Tasha: 把这么长的
Tasha: The long part.
Tasha: 这个呀哦哦哦要的
Tasha: This one, oh, oh, oh, yes.
Jake:要的
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: 嗯你看多了点
Tasha: Hmm, you see, there's a bit too much.
Tasha: 这这还没放开呢
Tasha: This, this isn't fully opened yet.
Tasha: 往那边去
Tasha: Move it over there.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Good.
Tasha: 了好了
Tasha: Done.
Alice:杨老板这个要不要先导一波呀
Alice: Jake, do you want to start a round of this first?
Alice:下午还录吗
Alice: Are we recording in the afternoon?
Jake:下下午当然录好了
Jake: Of course we are recording in the afternoon.
Jake:现在还有多少
Jake: How much time do we have left?
Alice:现在还有
Alice: We still have...
Jake:这个
Jake: This.
Jake:这么提还有多少
Jake: How much longer if we do this?
Jake:还有一个小时可以
Jake: Another hour, right?
Alice:40.77
Alice: 40.77.
Jake:等一个小时我们就倒呗
Jake: After an hour, we can flip it, right?
Alice:但是现在12点半了
Alice: But it's already 12:30 now.
Jake:等到饭来
Jake: Wait until lunch comes.
Jake:差不多
Jake: Almost.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Jake:倒一个小时吧
Jake: Count down one hour.
Tasha: 对 1点半
Tasha: Right, 1:30.
Tasha: 然后两点半开始
Tasha: Then we'll start at 2:30.
Jake:这样行吗
Jake: Is this okay?
Tasha: 可以是不是要把线也固定一下
Tasha: Sure, but shouldn't we also secure the wire?
Jake:是的第二轮哎
Jake: Yes, the second round. Hey,
Jake:歪了弯起来没关系
Jake: It's bent, but it's okay.
Tasha: 你前两次
Tasha: The first two times...
Jake:不行不行
Jake: No, no, no.
Jake:我靠我他妈手
Jake: Damn, my hand...
Jake:好残啊手
Jake: My hand is so messed up.
Jake:呵呵啊
Jake: Haha, ah
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Jake:没有没有没有
Jake: No, no, no.
Jake:我在这先固定一下
Jake: I'll secure this first.
Shure: 这黑色的人家是
Shure: The black one is...
Jake:哎呦我去哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my god, oh my god!
Tasha: 好了吗
Tasha: Is it done?
Jake:好了
Jake: Yes, it's done.
Katrina: 哇这房间好好看
Katrina: Wow, this room looks amazing.
Jake:确实确实有点牛逼
Jake: Indeed, it's quite impressive.
Lucia: 好好看
Lucia: So beautiful.
Katrina: 这是我梦想中的房间
Katrina: This is the room of my dreams.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Katrina: 你那个用美文胶粘的吗
Katrina: Did you use glue for this?
Tasha: 用胶纸还有好几个
Tasha: I used tape and a few others.
Tasha: 然后把还有下一个活
Tasha: Then there's another task.
Jake:好嘞你这个500
Jake: Alright, this is 500.
Katrina: 你这个500
Katrina: This is 500.
Katrina: 那能搞定吗
Katrina: Can you handle that?
Jake:刚刚取了20个快递
Jake: Just picked up 20 parcels.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Tasha: 好看你把这个粘到地图上
Tasha: Looks good, stick this to the map.
Katrina: 我把拍给我妈
Katrina: I'll send this to my mom.
Katrina:    我说我要这种房子
Katrina: And tell her I want this kind of room.
Jake:我把这个贴到
Jake: I'll stick this...
Jake:贴到这嗯
Jake: Stick this here, hmm.
Jake:这对贴一盘
Jake: Yes, stick it here.
Tasha: 贴一盘
Tasha: Stick it here.
Jake:贴一盘他有方向吗
Jake: Is there a direction to stick this?
Tasha: 他有方向
Tasha: Yes, there is.
Tasha: 好嘞然后把这个小勾子勾上去
Tasha: Alright, then hook this small hook up.
Shure: 别搞你搞不出来的
Shure: Don't mess with it, you can't do it.
Jake:没掉了
Jake: It didn't fall off.
Tasha: 下来吧你要在上面勾吗
Tasha: Come down, are you going to hook it up there?
Tasha: 你下来也能碰着吧
Tasha: You can reach it from down here, right?
Jake:碰不到
Jake: Can't reach.
Tasha: 你胡说八道啊
Tasha: You're talking nonsense.
Jake:是碰不到
Jake: Really can't reach.
Jake:就是碰不到
Jake: Just can't reach.
Tasha: 我把小明都踩住了
Tasha: I stepped on Xiaoming.
Tasha: 那你让一
Tasha: Move over.
Shure: 钢琴他都弹不好
Shure: He can't even play the piano well.
Shure: 这心乱了
Shure: His mind is in chaos.
Jake:哎还有吗
Jake: Hey, anything else?
Shure: 当然可以啦
Shure: Of course, we can.
Jake:我贴这儿
Jake: I'll stick it here.
Jake:然后贴一排
Jake: Then stick a row.
Jake:你就几个呀
Jake: How many do you have?
Jake:how many
Jake: How many?
Tasha: 你不用贴这么
Tasha: You don't need to stick so many.
Tasha: 你分散一点
Tasha: Spread them out a bit.
Jake:你看这第一个挂的
Jake: Look at the first one hanging.
Jake:我来挂
Jake: I'll hang it.
Jake:我去这确实有点牛逼
Jake: Wow, this is really impressive.
Jake:你这东西
Jake: Your stuff.
Jake:你这些东西
Jake:你没电了
Jake: You're out of battery.
Tasha: 这怎么就剩两个了
Tasha: Why are there only two left?
Tasha:  你拿走了多少个哦
Tasha: How many did you take?
Jake:你这都贴上去吗
Jake: Did you stick all of these?
Tasha: 对呀嗯
Tasha: Yes, I did.
Shure: 直到不能呼吸
Shure: Until I can't breathe.
Shure: 为了你
Shure: For you.
Shure: 愿意
Shure: Willing.
Shure: 如果全世
Shure: If the whole world.
其他人：操
Others: Damn.
Shure: 还有个桥吗这
Shure: Is there another bridge?
Jake:好听
Jake: Sounds good.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Shure: （歌词）不去珍惜
Shure: (Lyrics) Not cherishing.
Shure: （歌词）而你在这里我总记得在哪里
Shure: (Lyrics) And you're here, I always remember where.
Shure: （歌词）如果全世界我也可以忘记
Shure: (Lyrics) If I could forget the whole world.
Shure: （歌词）至少还有你值得我去珍惜
Shure: (Lyrics) At least there's you worth cherishing.
Shure: （歌词）你相信那是生命的奇迹
Shure: (Lyrics) You believe that's the miracle of life.
Jake:你有几个
Jake: How many do you have?
Jake:5个
Jake: 5.
Jake:6个 5个是吗
Jake: 6, 5 right?
Tasha: 还剩还剩12345
Tasha: There are still, there are still 12345.
Tasha: 还剩5个
Tasha: Still 5 left.
Jake:你要不先插个电吧
Jake: How about you plug it in first?
Tasha: 这个装饰很重要嘛
Tasha: Is this decoration very important?
Tasha:  装饰完就好好好好
Tasha: Once the decoration is done, it's good, good, good.
其他人：哎你们那个电脑不是黑的吗
Others: Hey, isn't your computer black?
其他人：我们都是深空灰的其实
Others: Ours are actually all space gray.
Tasha:  你怎么贴的歪七八扭的艺术
Tasha: Why did you stick it all crooked, it's art.
Jake:艺术
Jake: Art.
Jake:这很扭吗
Jake: Is it really that crooked?
Jake:哦这个确实有一点
Jake: Oh, this is indeed a bit.
Jake:有点过
Jake: A bit too much.
Jake:这些还行
Jake: These are fine.
其他人：确实黑一点
Others: It's indeed a bit darker.
其他人：黑的好看
Others: Black looks good.
Shure: 确实显大气
Shure: Indeed looks classy.
Tasha: 还差两个好
Tasha: Two more to go, alright.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:呃我没了
Jake: Uh, I'm out.
Tasha: 你没了对
Tasha: You're out, right.
Jake:给我两个
Jake: Give me two.
Shure: 我说插口也都是一样的
Shure: I said the ports are all the same.
Shure: 而且黑色的都显大感觉
Shure: And black ones all look more impressive.
其他人： 肯定给我买黑的
Others: Definitely buy me a black one.
Tasha: 你看你看
Tasha: Look, look.
Tasha: 这个均匀
Tasha: This is even.
Tasha: 现在开始
Tasha: Starting now.
Tasha: 开始往里面下叉
Tasha: Start inserting them inside.
Tasha: 这在来一个啊
Tasha: Here's another one.
Jake:不是这边吗
Jake: Isn't it on this side?
Jake:这边这这5个
Jake: This side, these 5.
Tasha: 好好
Tasha: Okay, okay.
Jake:稍微偏
Jake: It's a bit off.
Jake:这是一个正弦哇
Jake: This is a sine wave.
Tasha: 掉了一只名怎么办
Tasha: What if one of the names falls off?
Jake:不知道这个
Jake: I don't know about this.
Jake:没人知道
Jake: Nobody knows.
Tasha: 这个已经掉出来了
Tasha: This one has already fallen off.
Jake:钩子在哪呢
Jake: Where's the hook?
Tasha: 钩子在这
Tasha: The hook is here.
Jake:哪我研究研究
Jake: Let me study it.
Tasha: 那好你坐下来研究吧
Tasha: Alright, sit down and study it.
Tasha: 我去插电
Tasha: I'll go plug it in.
Jake:好插电是什么东西
Jake: Okay, what is this "plugging in"?
Tasha: 你不让我插电吗
Tasha: You don't want me to plug it in?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Jake:我靠这你妈怎么弄
Jake: Damn, how do we do this?
Katrina:  是什么装饰成这个东西
Katrina: What kind of decoration is this?
Jake:这是他的
Jake: This is his.
Jake:我给他针
Jake: I gave him the needle.
Jake:我给打工呢
Jake: I'm working for him.
Jake:哎呦我操
Jake: Oh my god.
其他人：我靠不是
Others: Damn, no.
Shure: 红尘客栈
Shure: The Red Dust Inn.
其他人：对这两个一模一样
Others: Yes, these two are exactly the same.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 怎么要的东西这么多呢
Shure: Why do you need so many things?
Shure: 怎么野花
Shure: Why the wildflowers?
Shure: 家花哪有野花香是吗
Shure: Home flowers can't compare to wildflowers, right?
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Shure: 懂了
Shure: Got it.
其他人：你给他端起来放这顶吧
Others: You should lift it up and put it on top.
Shure: 谢斌竹来来来
Shure: Xie Binzhu, come on, come on.
其他人：谢明珠切冰竹
Others: Xie Mingzhu, cut the ice bamboo.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
其他人：借个充电宝
Others: Can I borrow a power bank?
Jake:没
Jake: No.
Jake:当然不能拔啊
Jake: Of course, you can't unplug it.
Jake:实在不能拿走
Jake: You really can't take it away.
Shure: 哎压了压了压了压了
Shure: Hey, it's pressed, it's pressed, it's pressed.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Tasha: 不好意思我靠碰摄像头了是吗
Tasha: Sorry, did I bump into the camera?
Shure: 你瞅着点
Shure: Watch out
Shure: 你底下看着点
Shure: Look below
Jake:我我下去给你拿一个
Jake: I'll go get one for you
Alice: 你的电充满了吗
Alice: Is your battery fully charged?
Jake:我看一下
Jake: Let me check
Jake:你你这个还有多少电
Jake: How much battery do you have left?
Alice:不知道呀不知道呀
Alice: I have no idea, no idea
Jake: 80
Jake:眼镜上面呢
Jake: What about on the glasses?
Jake:忙完了一百
Jake: When we're done, it'll be a hundred
Alice:100
Alice: 100
Jake:嗯一百行行行
Jake: Yeah, a hundred is fine, fine
Alice:有人用这个吗
Alice: Is someone using this?
Jake:那拿这个好
Jake: Then take this one
Alice:要不先用这个
Alice: How about using this first
其他人：这么好看的吗
Others: Is it really that nice?
Jake:楼下怎么样啊
Jake: How's it downstairs?
Jake:现在干净吗
Jake: Is it clean now?
Shure: 只能说8分干净
Shure: I'd say it's about 80% clean
其他人：非常干净
Others: It's very clean
Jake:哈哈你们这
Jake: Haha, you guys...
Jake:呵
Jake: Huh
其他人：我反正看非常干净
Others: I think it's very clean anyway
Jake:外边呢
Jake: What about outside?
Jake:干净个球干净出去
Jake: Hurry up and get out there quickly
其他人：然后你昨天不在这附近
Others: And you weren't around here yesterday
其他人：咋了被劫者说
Others: What happened, did someone get robbed?
其他人：嗯?
其他人：没事
Jake:把那个外面收拾收拾吧嗯
Jake: Clean up outside, alright
Jake:对楼下外头
Jake: Yes, outside downstairs
Jake:刘帅干嘛呢
Jake: What's Choiszt doing?
Jake:下去哈哈
Jake: Go downstairs, haha
其他人：哦我的好像满了
Others: Oh, mine seems to be full
Jake:你看看是不是满了
Jake: Check if it's really full
Jake:我觉得不是满了
Jake: I don't think it's full
Shure: 因为他灯是亮的哦
Shure: Because the light is on
Shure: grass is crashed
Shure: The grass is crashed
Jake:crashed那就再restart
Jake: If it's crashed, then restart it
其他人：一会儿咱吃饭在二楼
Others: We'll have dinner on the second floor in a bit.
Jake:吃饭在二楼
Jake: Dinner on the second floor.
其他人：那在二楼怎么吃啊
Others: How do we eat on the second floor?
Jake:那就一楼吧
Jake: Then let's do the first floor.
Jake:一楼一楼一楼一楼一楼
Jake: First floor, first floor, first floor, first floor, first floor.
Jake:总有地方能吃
Jake: There's always a place to eat.
Jake:哪个老板顶饿
Jake: Which boss can endure hunger?
Jake:哈哈哈哦
Jake: Hahaha oh.
其他人：杨老板说你为什么用其他的
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 我靠走这么远
Shure: Damn, we walked so far.
其他人：马上用斯坦福的钢琴给大家弹
Others: We're about to play the Stanford piano for everyone.
Tasha: 斯坦福
Tasha: Stanford.
其他人：必须的 800万
Others: Of course, it costs 8 million.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha.
Jake:完了完了完了完了都录上了
Jake: Oh no, oh no, oh no, oh no, it's all recorded.
Shure: 漏气了
Shure: It's leaking.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:what should i do
Jake: What should I do?
Jake:哎哟好看
Jake: Oh wow, looks good.
Jake:我的这个在哪儿啊
Jake: Where's mine?
其他人：你连上了是吧
Others: You connected, right?
Shure: 连上了
Shure: Connected.
Shure: 来吧用
Shure: Come on, use it.
其他人：我操
Others: Damn.
Shure: 卧槽哈哈好
Shure: Whoa, haha, alright.
Jake:这能吃吗
Jake: Can we eat this?
其他人：啊
Others: Huh?
Jake:真的就一个吗
Jake: Is there really just one?
其他人：能吃真的
Others: Yes, you can really eat it.
Jake:问问啊问问
Jake: Ask, ask.
其他人：为啥问问能不能吃啊
Others: Why ask if you can eat it?
Shure: 呵呵呵你别一脸高潮的样子好吗
Shure: Haha, can you not look so ecstatic?
其他人：批准了
Others: Approved.
Jake:批准了我操
Jake: Approved, damn.
其他人：这个你吃吗
Others: Are you eating this?
Jake:这我不吃
Jake: I'm not eating this.
Jake:吃不动了
Jake: Can't eat anymore.
Jake:今天要吃很多的你知道吗
Jake: You know we have to eat a lot today, right?
Jake:啊今天要吃很多的
Jake: Ah, we have to eat a lot today.
Jake:因为要做很多
Jake: Because we have a lot to do.
其他人：为什么
Others: Why?
其他人：今天还要做啊少做点
Others: We still have to do more today? Do less.
Jake:吃不动我饿
Jake: I can't eat anymore, I'm hungry.
其他人：这个叫半个
Others: This counts as half.
Jake:晚上吃不吃
Jake: Are we eating tonight or not?
Jake:这个叫半个
Jake: This counts as half.
Jake:你拿别人吃
Jake: You take it and give it to others.
其他人：他们都不吃我靠
Others: They all don't want it, damn.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Damn.
其他人：死我也不吃
Others: I'd rather die than eat it.
其他人：那我吃了
Others: Then I'll eat it.
Jake:没有
Jake: No.
Jake:没有一点办法
Jake: There's no way.
Tasha: 还有最后一个项目
Tasha: There's one last task.
Shure: （歌词）没有一点点防备
Shure: (lyrics) No preparation at all.
Shure: （歌词）也没有一丝顾虑
Shure: (lyrics) And no hesitation.
Jake:你要干嘛
Jake: What are you doing?
Tasha:  穿上了吗没有
Tasha: Are you dressed or not?
Jake:马上马上很快很快
Jake: Soon, soon, very soon.
Shure: 垫个垫应该更高一点哎
Shure: Adding a cushion might make it higher.
Jake:就凭这句话你就得有一只offer
Jake: Just for that statement, you deserve an offer.
Jake:录下来了
Jake: It's recorded.
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my god.
Jake:你怎么这么多东西
Jake: Why do you have so much stuff?
Tasha: 你应该说我怎么这么会想
Tasha: You should say why do I have so many ideas.
Jake:你怎么这么会想
Jake: Why do you have so many ideas.
Tasha: 这样子的
Tasha: Like this.
Tasha: 放在这个窗户的前面
Tasha: Put it in front of the window.
Tasha: 所有东西的后面做背景板
Tasha: Use it as a background for everything.
Jake:贴哪了贴哪
Jake: Where should we stick it?
Tasha: 嗯我想的是两个挂钩挂这两边
Tasha: Hmm, I was thinking of using two hooks on either side.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Jake:胶呢贴哪
Jake: Where's the glue, where should we stick it?
Jake:贴什么呀
Jake: What should we stick it with?
Jake:用什么贴
Jake: What to use to stick it?
Tasha: 好看吗
Tasha: Does it look good?
Jake:好看
Jake: It looks good.
Tasha: 你别动
Tasha: Don't move.
Jake:我不动
Jake: I'm not moving
Tasha: 两个挂钩钩嘛
Tasha: Just hook the two hooks.
Tasha: 然后上面有个小钩子
Tasha: Then there's a small hook on top.
Tasha: 你会钩吧
Tasha: Can you hook it?
Tasha: 这样钩啊
Tasha: Hook it like this.
Tasha: 别钩反了
Tasha: Don't hook it the wrong way.
Jake:哈哈不至于不至于不至于
Jake: Haha, no way, no way.
Jake:哎呦我靠
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Jake:哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my!
Jake:可爱踩这
Jake: Cute, step here.
Tasha: 不不不不就是弄直了就行弄直
Tasha: No no no, just straighten it, just straighten it.
Jake:要不让他往中间摆摆
Jake: How about we move it to the center?
Jake:我那个钩我一会搞一下
Jake: I'll fix that hook later.
Jake:那这个我也要搞一下
Jake: And I'll fix this one too.
Jake:所以我先搞那个
Jake: So I'll fix that one first.
Jake:你在这撑一下
Jake: You hold this for a bit.
Jake:找一个好的居中点
Jake: Find a good center point.
Tasha:  行了
Tasha: Done.
Jake:行了当然行了
Jake: Done? Of course, it's done.
Jake:行的不得了就这样
Jake: It's perfect, just like this.
Tasha: 给我撑直就行
Tasha: Just hold it straight for me.
Jake:好了没挂上我来挂
Jake: Done, haven't hung it up? Let me do it.
Jake:牛皮
Jake: Awesome.
Tasha: 好看吗
Jake:你又没电了
Jake: You're out of battery again.
Tasha:  没开嗯嘻嘻嘻
Tasha: It's not on, hehe.
Tasha: 抹的是什么
Tasha: What did you use to wipe it?
Jake:好看
Jake: Looks good.
Tasha: 摆台
Tasha: Display stand.
Tasha: 我们这个怎么弄呢
Tasha: How do we do this?
Jake:你插电了吗
Jake: Did you plug it in?
Jake:充 一会
Jake: Charge it for a bit.
Tasha: 这个藏起来这个丑
Tasha: Hide this, it's ugly.
Jake:好看
Jake: Looks good.
Jake:确实牛逼
Jake: Really impressive.
Jake:这怎么热风
Jake: How is this hot air?
Tasha: 热风
Tasha: Hot air.
Jake:不失败好看
Jake: Not a failure, looks good.
Jake:可以
Jake: Alright.
Jake:你可以开了
Jake: You can turn it on now.
Jake:收拾完可以开了
Jake: Once we finish cleaning up, we can start.
Jake:挺有意思
Jake: Pretty interesting.
Jake:来
Jake: Come on.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Alice:yeah
Alice: Yeah.
其他人： 我是收拾完之后你做蛋糕
Others: After I finish cleaning up, you make the cake.
Jake:吃完之后吃饭
Jake: After we finish eating, we'll have a meal.
Jake:做蛋糕差不多对就结了
Jake: Making the cake should be almost done, then we're finished.
Jake:是吧把这把
Jake: Right, this one.
Jake:这可能摆摆摆
Jake: Maybe arrange this, arrange this.
Jake:椅子稍微摆摆
Jake: Arrange the chairs a bit.
Jake:难忘
Jake: Unforgettable.
Jake:喂
Jake: Hey.
Jake:哎好好好好好好
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake:谢谢嗯
Jake: Thank you, mm-hmm.
Tasha: 好麻的麻麻麻酱酱的味道
Tasha: It's so numbing, the numbing sauce taste.
Jake:外边有人收拾吗
Jake: Is anyone cleaning up outside?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:可以来准备开饭吧
Jake: We can start preparing for the meal.
Tasha: 哇吃不下了
Tasha: Wow, I can't eat anymore.
Tasha: 怎么回事
Tasha: What's going on?
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Tasha: 累了喝饮料
Tasha: Tired, have a drink.